autorisé par les autorités russes le 11
août 2020 le spoutnik v se fait encore
très discret en europe
si une soixantaine de nations dont le
monde utilisent aujourd'hui le sérum
russe elle les pays du vieux continent
semblent toujours autant réticents
c'est pourquoi une délégation d'experts
de l'agencé européenne des médicaments
est en visite cette semaine à moscou
nous avons besoin de documents que nous
pouvons passer en revue pour le moment
nous n'avons pas de données sur les
effets secondaires concernant les
personnes vaccinées
nous sommes dans l'inconnu et c'est
pourquoi je déconseille vivement de
délivrer une autorisation nationale en
urgence seulement l'homologation du
spoutnik v semble particulièrement
longue
à titre de comparaison l union
européenne qu au monde près de 300
millions de doses du sérum britanno
suédois astrazeneca en 2020 alors que
l'avis favorable de l'agencé européenne
des médicaments n'arrive qu'en janvier
depuis son autorisation de mise sur le
marché à 15 personnes sont mortes en
france et plusieurs cas de thrombose ont
été détectés après l'injection même
empressement pour le vaccin américain
pfizer validé au moins de quatre
semaines par les autorités européennes
l'homologation du spoutnik v voilà donc
une idée qui divise les 27 l'allemagne
se dit pourtant prête à commander le
sérum russe au delà de nos différences
politiques qui sont importantes il est
possible de coopérer sur le plan
humanitaire
dans le contexte de la pandémie je
préférerais une commande européenne mais
si ce n'était pas le cas nous devrions
emprunter une voie allemande ce qui est
possible et ce que nous ferions
son de cloche différent en france
interrogé sur tf1 le 21 mars dernier
thierry breton commissaire européen au
marché intérieur assure que le pays
n'aura pas besoin du spoutnik v on
n'aura absolument pas besoin de spoutnik
vais pas d'autres vaccins non plus il
faut maintenant que ceux qui sont là
soit produit en masse est administré en
masse en février dernier la revue
scientifique britannique 27 qualifie de
spoutnik v2 sûrs et efficaces concernant
les conclusions de l'agencé européenne
des médicaments sur le sujet il faudra
encore attendre jusqu'à la fin du mois
de juin